have both a true rife and an atelier ramen rife machine are the computers slash programs interchangeable
no no they're not so they're different you cannot run true rife programs on the atelier
ramen nor could you you definitely cannot run atelier ramen programs on the true rife
um so no they're not interchangeable so you can't change computers and run a true rife program
on your atelier ramen vice versa how about the foot bath pieces that i and pro wave will that
the atelier ramen will it might actually fit into that thing but you're gonna you do not do that
so they're not interchange the only thing that would be interchangeable would be the bulbs
so the bulbs are interchangeable that's the only thing that would be interchangeable so
something happened to your true rife bulb you could use the one that came with your
atelier ramen with the true rife um that's the only thing that would be interchangeable